Quand vous n'insistez que sur les plus brillants des élèves,
les disparités deviennent automatiquement plus grandes,
et vous voyez que cette bulle se dirige lentement dans l'autre direction,
mais cela n'empêche pas que c'est une amélioration impressionnante.
Une remise en état majeure de l'éducation polonaise
a considérablement réduit les disparités entre les écoles,
a redressé bon nombre d'écoles à faibles performances
et a haussé les performances d'environ une demi-année scolaire.
Vous pouvez voir que c'est le cas d'autres pays aussi.
Le Portugal a pu consolider son système scolaire fragmenté,
hausser la qualité et améliorer l'égalité,
et la Hongrie en a fait de même.
Donc ce que vous voyez en fait c'est beaucoup de changements.
Et même ceux qui se plaignent et disent que
les positions relatives des pays
selon une norme comme PISA n'est qu'un artefact de culture,
de facteurs économiques, de questions sociales,
de l'homogénéité des sociétés, etc.
Ces personnes doivent reconnaître qu'améliorer l'éducation est possible.
La Pologne n'a pas changé sa culture.
Elle n'a pas changé son économie. Elle n'a pas changé
la composition de sa population.
Elle n'a pas licencié ses enseignants. Elle a changé ses politiques
et ses pratiques en matière d'éducation. Impressionnant.
La question qui s'impose est donc : Qu'est-ce-qu'on apprend
de ces pays dans le quadrant vert
qui ont atteint de hauts niveaux d'égalité
et de performances et qui ont amélioré les résultats ?
Et bien sûr : si ça a marché dans un contexte particulier,
peut-on en faire un modèle pour les autres ?
On ne peut bien sûr pas copier-coller les systèmes éducatifs
mais ces comparaisons font ressortir un nombre de facteurs
partagés par les systèmes très performants.
On est tous d'accord que l'éducation est importante.
Tout le monde le dit.
Mais le test de vérité est : comment comparer cette priorité
avec les autres priorités ?
Comment les pays payent-ils leurs enseignants
par rapport à d'autres employés hautement qualifiés ?
Voudriez-vous que votre enfant devienne enseignant
plutôt qu'avocat ?
Comment les médias parlent-ils des écoles et des enseignants ?
Ce sont là les questions importantes, et ce qu'on a appris
de PISA est que dans les systèmes éducatifs très performants
les dirigeants ont aujourd'hui convaincu leurs citoyens de faire des choix
qui font valoir leur éducation, leur avenir,
plus que la consommation.
Vous n'allez pas le croire,
mais il y a des pays où l'endroit le plus attrayant
n'est pas le centre commercial, mais l'école.
Ces choses existent vraiment.
Mais miser sur l'éducation
n'est qu'un élément du tableau.
L'autre élément est la conviction que tout enfant
est capable de réussir.
Il y a des pays où la ségrégation entre les élèves
se produit très tôt.
Les élèves sont triés,
ce qui reflète la croyance que seuls quelques uns
peuvent atteindre les normes internationales.
Mais d'habitude, cela est lié à des disparités sociales prononcées.
Si vous allez au Japon en Asie, ou en Finlande en Europe,
les parents et les enseignants dans ces pays
s'attendent à la réussite de chaque élève,
et vous verrez cela reflété dans le comportement des élèves.
Lorsqu'on a demandé aux élèves ce qui permettait
de réussir en maths,
les élèves en Amérique du Nord répondaient
que c'est une question de talent.
Si je ne suis pas né génie en maths, je ferais mieux d'étudier autre chose.
9 étudiants japonais sur 10 répondent :
ça dépend de mon investissement, de mon propre effort,
et cela en dit long sur le système dont ils font partie.
Dans le passé, des élèves différents recevaient la même éducation.
les super-performants selon PISA acceptent la diversité
avec des pratiques pédagogiques différentes.
Ils se rendent compte que
les élèves ordinaires ont des talents extraordinaires,
et ils personnalisent les opportunités d'apprentissage.
Les systèmes très performants partagent aussi
des normes claires et ambitieuses à tous les niveaux.
Chaque élève sait ce qui compte.
Chaque élève connaît les conditions du succès.
Et la qualité d'un système éducatif n'est
nulle part supérieure à la qualité de ses enseignants.
Les systèmes très performants sont très méticuleux
dans le choix de leurs enseignants
et dans la formation qu'ils leurs donnent.
Ils cherchent à améliorer les performances
des enseignants en difficulté,
et à structurer la rémunération des enseignants.
Ils offrent un environnement favorable à la collaboration
entre les enseignants dans le but d'établir les bonnes pratiques.
Ils ouvrent les voies à l'accomplissement des enseignants
dans leurs carrières.
Dans les systèmes éducatifs bureaucratiques,
les enseignants se retrouvent souvent sans supervision en classe
mais avec tellement de prescriptions sur ce qu'il faut enseigner.
Les systèmes très performants ont une idée très claire sur ce qu'est une bonne performance.
Ils fixent des normes très ambitieuses, mais ils permettent
à leurs enseignants de décider
ce qu'ils enseignent à leurs élèves tous les jours.
Dans le passé, on se souciait du rôle de l'éducation comme fournisseur de sagesse.
Aujourd'hui, le défi est d'avoir des acteurs de l'éducation fournir eux-mêmes la sagesse.
On est passé au-dessus des formes administratives
de comptes-rendus et de contrôle,
c'est à dire, comment vérifier si les gens font ce qu'ils ont à faire,
vers des formes professionnelles d'organisation du travail.
Ils permettent à leurs enseignants d'innover en matière de pédagogie.
Ils leurs offrent les moyens de développement nécessaires
pour établir des pratiques pédagogiques solides.
Dans le passé, l'objectif était la standardisation et la conformité.
Les systèmes très performants ont rendu les enseignants
et les directeurs d'écoles inventifs.
Dans le passé, la politique visait les résultats
et la manière de les atteindre.
Les systèmes très performants ont aidé les enseignants
et les directeurs d'écoles à considérer l'enseignant voisin,
l'école voisine.
Le résultat le plus impressionnant des systèmes de haut-niveau
est qu'ils réalisent leurs hautes performances partout dans le système.
Vous avez vu les résultats excellents de la Finlande selon PISA,
mais ce qui constitue l'excellence de la Finlande
est que seulement 5 % de la variation des performances
parmi les élèves est due aux écoles.
Toutes les écoles réussissent.
C'est là que le succès est systémique.
Et comment le font-ils ?
Ils investissent des ressources là où ils peuvent créer le plus grand impact.
Ils recrutent les directeurs les plus résistants pour les écoles les plus difficiles,
et les enseignants les plus talentueux
pour les classes présentant le plus de défis.
Dernier point, tout aussi important, ces pays mettent en place
des politiques à travers tous les domaines de l'ordre public.
Ils les rendent cohérentes pendant de longues périodes,
et ils s'assurent que leur travail est appliqué de manière régulière.
Le fait de connaître la démarche des pays ayant réussi
ne nous explique pas comment nous améliorer.
C'est évident et c'est là que résident certaines
limitations aux comparaisons internationales de PISA.
C'est là que d'autres formes de recherche doivent intervenir,
et c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle PISA ne s'aventure pas à
dicter la démarche à suivre aux pays.
Mais sa force réside dans les informations
qu'elle donne sur ce que font les autres.
L'exemple de PISA montre que les données
peuvent avoir plus d'impact que le contrôle administratif des subventions financières,
contrôle qui nous permet généralement de gérer les systèmes éducatifs.
Certains disent que
changer l'administration de l'éducation
est comme faire déplacer des cimetières.
Vous ne pouvez pas vraiment compter sur les gens qui y sont pour vous aider. (rires)
Mais PISA a démontré les possibilités en matière d'éducation.
Elle a aidé les pays à voir que s'améliorer est possible.
Elle a empêché les suffisants de trouver des excuses.
Et elle a aidé des pays à fixer d'importants objectifs
en termes de résultats mesurables réalisés par les leaders mondiaux.
Si nous pouvons aider tout enfant, tout enseignant, toute école,
tout directeur et tout parent à voir le degré d'amélioration possible,
que les possibilités d'améliorer l'éducation sont illimitées,
nous avons alors établi les bases
pour de meilleures politiques et des vies meilleures.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)